news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
don't forget that membership is the
number one way
the david pakman show is funded grab a
membership and get all of the associated
benefits including the daily bonus show
world
famous by signing up at joinpacman.com
let's go to um let's go to the phones
at 617-830-4750
starting today with our caller from the
980 area code
caller from 980 what's your name and
where are you calling from today
hello yes that's you sweet
hi uh my name is stan i'm calling from
north carolina
what's going on oh gosh so i just have
one kind of like one long question so
like
um so like i know i've noticed that you
a few other like uh like
left independence voices on youtube
have like made this claim about like
vote out donald trump
yes fine and then we'll and then like
we'll push
biden left or we'll hold him accountable
and like i just don't get that i kind of
see that as basically
a big as a big of a lie as like
oh biden's going to be the next fb fdr
or whatever just because like what level
of
protesting organizing is going to push
biden left that 200 dead americans
haven't pushed him left that a millions
of
unemployed americans who've also lost
their health care
hasn't pushed him left that like months
of protesting
against police brutality has it pushed
him left and we still got the cop for a
vp
well hold on a second uh but let's let's
examine that if we can
if you compare joe biden today to joe
biden even five years ago
nevermind 10 or 15 or 47 as donald trump
likes to do
the move to the left has been dramatic
has it not i mean you look at biden's
position today
on health care which includes you know
again it's not single payer but it's
public option open to lowering the
medicare age by five or ten years which
would give millions of people access
subsidizing to a higher level of income
right all these
we're talking about tens of millions of
more people getting health care you look
at
cannabis just coming out and saying full
federal decriminalization
of cannabis like he's already moved to
the left and i think what we mean when
we say we continue to push
is when we look at the house and senate
the more
left those legislative bodies go the
more progressive will be the bills that
get put on president joe biden's desk it
all seems coherent to me
but i i still just don't quite see it
just
that's like you don't see it okay but
you said it was one of the biggest lies
you've heard that
who's lying who are the people lying
like you it may not happen and you may
not
be confident in it but i don't know that
it's a big lie
it's just not like let's say like you or
perhaps like
maybe jameson the young turks or
david dole from rational national like
a few of these will say push by and left
i'm just kind of curious
what exactly does that look like just
because like millions of people
lost their health insurance 200 000 dead
americans
and buying still won't endorse a full
like medicare for all universal health
care plan
and even then like on a public option
front i'm pretty sure there's like
a political article that says that they
might not even push a public option just
to get
like some brownie points for working
with republicans
okay well that's that's speculative and
we have to see if that happens but
i just i think i just disagree with with
the framing i mean it's
you know we have to understand what what
do we have control over and what do we
not have control over
different people had different
preferences in the primary biden's the
nominee
now the options we we now now that's
beyond our control now the option is
who's president trump or biden
we can vote if biden is president then
what can we control we can't go back and
make bernie the president
so all we can do is lobby and elect
the most progressive possible senate and
house like we just we have to focus on
what we can do and i just don't see sort
of the point of
speculating that people are lying about
pushing biden left it's
what can we do and that is actually
something that is a coherent cohesive
strategy if joe biden becomes president
no so it's not like people will push him
it's not that like the lie is that
people will want to push him left
okay is it the idea of like
him being pushable to the left but the
last 10 years are evidence look at
biden's
look at biden's policy on health care
economics and energy today
and look at what he was part of in terms
of policy
during the obama administration i mean
even in the last four years joe biden
has been pulled significantly to the
left
like but didn't it doesn't even hillary
clinton suggest
an even lower age for medicaid for
medicare
that may be but you look at the sum
total i mean look at the
look at the economic policy that joe
biden is proposing look at uncapping
social security tax doing away with a
lower rate for capital gains
an alternative a minimum tax for
corporations like the
these are big things that hillary
clinton from what i recall was not even
talking about in 2016. listen i gotta
run because i've got a lot of people
holding but i think i would i would
maybe rethink some of your ideas and see
if they're really passing the sniff test
okay all right my friend thank you so
much appreciate the call